pensé que ce serait un combat plus dur
ma famille en bave à cause de moi
houston
tu te barres tu le sais tu peux plus
beau que c'est comme ça je serais pas là
sans ma femme au rythme
la cour a conscience du drame qui a
frappé votre famille néanmoins vous avez
choisi d'adopter un comportement
dangereux
les services sociaux conserveront dans
la garde de l'enfant jusqu'à ce que son
père démontre sa capacité à être un
parent responsable
jean avec la non non je dois y aller
seul quel bon vent amène billy obam
assam cherche un boulot
j'aimerais bien entraîner pour toi c'est
trop stricte qui fait pour monter sur le
ring je vais récupérer ma fille je sais
rien du tout
peut pas perdre ma fille
ses tombeurs toiture
destin est entre tes mains